[Music]
chuck yeah
we had a gas pipeline hacked tell me
about it
oh man yeah man disrupting the the fuel
pumps
in the east coast of the united states
and driving prices up
yeah okay and that got me thinking about
gasoline
that's what did it okay sorry
no i just got i got thinking i just want
to share some thoughts i had okay
about gasoline i am intrigued so it's a
reminder first of all
how dependent we are or at least that
our transportation grid is dependent
on this one source of fuel gasoline
okay so so that's a that makes
gasoline a strategic commodity just want
to say i love it
i love your government dirty talk there
strategic
commodity yes i'm not a
government speak so so a couple of
things about
gasoline the reason why it is so
hard to shake the gas habit yeah is
uh yeah in the form of oil but it's just
sitting there in the ground
and chemically it contains so much
energy
in the form of chemical bonds did you
just take it out of the ground
and it used to be over here now i
put it over there oh you need energy
over there let me
take it there right so so you it the
transportability of it
is a very hard habit to shake it's so
transportable that you can transport it
and
use it at the same time
[Laughter]
that's exactly right right it's like let
me let me put 15 gallons of gas in my
car
use that gas to get to my garage and i
still got gas left over exactly
okay so part of the evidence
that it contains this energy is that
gasoline
is flammable okay you know extinguish
all matches and cigarettes and thing
when you're at the pump
and now all the gas gas stations have
these uh
uh fire extinguisher hose you ever look
up at a gas station yeah they have them
right above the pump now
right right above the pump and so now
those tv
scenes where the whole gas station is on
plan that can't do it anymore you can't
do it anymore because it all gets
extinguished yeah and they all use like
foam or halon so it's not even like
you know yeah exactly exactly so just a
reminder that it's flammable but
there's something i think you should
know about this
so so flammability is not
whether the thing itself will burn
but will it burn in the presence of
oxygen typically that's combustion
wait a minute flat inflammable
means flammable
don't get me started on words that
should be different and are not
okay you know when i was 13
i looked up the definition northerly
because i heard
weather forecasters say northerly winds
today going 15. so i looked up northerly
and it said coming out of the north that
was the first definition
the second definition
going towards the north it was like what
the
what about i'm in middle school and
i'm supposed to make sense of this
please right grown-ups can you do better
than this
here's my point if you have gasoline
there's no oxygen in it to make it
combust
so if you were quick or if you came in
from below
you could take a match and extinguish it
in the liquid gasoline a trick that i
don't see
it's because gasoline is not itself
flammable but you know what is it's
vapors right and gasoline is
vaporous down to very low
temperatures most things they get less
smelly
when you cool them down right that's why
you heat food and you
and the aromas and all of this gasoline
at 100 degrees
50 0 10 below 20 below
that is cranking out the molecules
stinks
of gasoline okay and what are you
smelling you're smelling
gasoline molecules vaporizing up
and when you have a gasoline molecule
floating above the liquid
it is surrounded by free oxygen
right in the air so when you take a
match and come
near a supply of gasoline
it will ignite long before that match
gets to the surface of the liquid it
will ignite the vapors
and since you're like an american guy
you and you own a home you've probably
tried to help the coals ignite by
throwing a little gasoline
of course now that's a fire that's
that's this is like entry this is like
like
rights of passage of course except for
the barbecue right tell you something
you ain't had a barbecue until you had
to call the fire department
okay so so if you've ever done this
you just might you only do it once and
yet wait till your eyebrows grow back
right but to take gasoline near a fire
what ignites is the vapor
and that's how it can make this what
looks what's basically what's a
conflagration
a conflagration as distinct from an
explosion is a moving wave of fire
through whatever it is that's that's
flammable
and so if you have uh fumes right so
here they go
here they go if you ignite that those
fumes will ignite
and where they're going to take you to
all the way back to the source
yes okay that is the backdraft yes and
once you do that
then the whole thing goes because right
above the surface of that
it is more it and you'll you'll it
happens quickly
and fast and you basically take out the
whole room
so funny you bring this up right now
okay
oh sorry yeah cause i guess was on my
mind i'm sorry no
by the way so my sister and i were
having this conversation
yesterday because she had a fire
in her how in her home and
her uh housemate came downstairs
and panicked when she saw the fire and
my sister
was trying to get the fire extinguisher
going
and the young woman who never took a
science course in her class
in her life ran to the door
and opened the door to let the smoke out
oh okay all right yeah to let in more
oxygen is what's happening
right and boom and then well if you
don't know the chemistry of that
it's a problem yeah and so and so for
example chuck do you remember the scene
in in raiders of the lost ark where
uh indiana jones gets into a fight
underneath that nazi airplane
um at the at the at the camp at the
excavation camp
and they they get into a fight but and
somebody shoots a gun and
there's gasoline uh you know uh spilling
out of the tank
and it's spilling as the plane rotates
so there's a there's like a path of
gasoline
and then there's some other fire and
then it ignites right
does the whole thing blow up at once no
it's a moving flame
on the on the vapors of the gas that
finally makes its way over to the tank
right okay so gasoline itself is not the
thing it's got to actually catch the
vapors that's all i'm saying
oh by the way you know what volatile
means in geochemistry
i do not volatile simply means it's easy
to evaporate
oh okay that's a very simple easy
explanation
i really only know one explanation of
volatile and it has to do with
relationships
i don't want to get into your therapy
sessions here yeah
yeah and pretty much all of mine have
been exactly that
uh there's only one factor that remains
the same in all of them but we won't
talk about
the volatility yeah so i just want to
say that
in common parlance when we think of
something that's volatile we think of
the fact that it can ignite and by the
way alcohol is among them right when you
when you light alcohol
you're first lighting the fumes of the
alcohol and
then the fumes will just stay there
alcohol is not as explosive
uh chemically as gasoline is but if you
take a pool of alcohol and light it
just watch it it's basically the the
fumes above
the flames last night look right the
actual liquid never catches fire it's
not actually on fire right it's the same
with the with the sterno
underneath the absolutely the sternal
cup
the flame is always hovering right at
the opening of the start with the
opening exactly yeah
you got it dude that is so cool all
right that's it we got it that's our
that's our celebration of gasoline there
you go that's the only celebration of
gasoline because the take away
green energy people that's the takeaway
here green energy yeah time to go to
electricity
watch other people wait online for their
one gallon of ration gas
all right this is star talk explainer
neil degrasse tyson
keep looking up
you